megan is with us in Cleveland Ohio I'm
Megan
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
how are you better than I deserve
how can I help I am calling because my
husband and I are coming out of a
bankruptcy about and about a year and a
half ago and we took two FPU and so
we're kind of craving our debt snowball
and going through everything one of my
student loans is no longer listed on our
credit reports and so we have no contact
information I have no idea how to get
ahold of these people my husband student
loan and so we're kind of unsure what to
do do we just leave it alone
I'm afraid of Chase knocking on our door
someday oh you're gonna come after your
student student loans are not bankrupt
of all and they're gonna come find you
it's just sitting up there piling up we
need to find it but you don't have a
single piece of information on this one
my husband's not very organized I'm much
more organized when it comes to our
financials and so I guess the loan was
sold and resold and transferred because
it was a private student loan your case
so so you know it was a change do you
have the all chase account number that's
the first place you would start call
chase with that account number and say I
know this was sold can you tell me who
it was sold to I can tell you then you
think it was sold again you call those
people and you go I know this was sold
can you tell me how it was sold to until
they finally say oh no we own it and so
forth now is this a Sallie Mae loan or a
private loan this is a private loan it's
not a Sallie Mae is my government
insured no you're sure yes then why
didn't it get bankrupted with the
bankruptcy that's what I'm thinking may
have happened it's not a matter it's not
up to the lender as to whether they got
bankrupted it's up to you and your
attorney so your Chapter seven should
call you should have had a matrix for
your debts did you do a chapter 7 yeah
okay you should have Anna Mae
tricks for your debts and listed all
your debts to the best of your knowledge
even if you didn't list a debt it can
still be bankrupted did they not put
anything down for this one at home did
we did and we included it as a student
loan and we were under the impression
through our attorney that it you know
wouldn't matter whether we put it down
or not I mean we still did include
everything with that okay it doesn't
matter but if your attorney thought it
was a Sallie Mae your attorney was
telling you that Sallie Mae's are not
bankrupt able that's that survives the
bankruptcy if it's a private loan it's
just like a personal line of credit is
what it is and it completely was
bankrupted okay so did you put down
Chase student loan some amount on your
matrix yeah I'm not worried about it it
was a bank right it was bankrupted if
your bankruptcy was discharged yeah okay
then if someone so comes up you got and
says we you owe us a student loan you
say no that was bankrupted as it was
originally chased and that was what was
listed on the bankruptcy matrix and
nobody could find you people but you
know it's cleared it should be cleared I
don't know why your attorney would think
that's not bankrupted I think they must
have thought it was a Sallie Mae loan
possibly I mean like I said my husband's
not very organized but I mean we did say
it was a private loan I know that no I
don't know that a private student loan
is basically an unsecured loan it's just
a loan that was used for college okay
just use like a personal line of credit
for college is the same thing a
government insured Sallie Mae loan is
not bankrupt about a personal line of
credit is bankrupt but will you see the
difference yeah I mean we have plenty of
there we have plenty of Sally is the
tutor pass yeah sally sally survives
she's a resilient old broad and so you
just can't get rid of her until you pay
her off in a victor but the other stuff
that's what you're facing I wouldn't
worry about that right now
I don't think it's going to come up if
it does come up you'll have to go back
and do this later I filed bankruptcy
thirty years ago and two years later
American Express came at me again on a
similar situation that was listed on the
thing but it wasn't they didn't get
notified because of the way it was
listed they don't have to
notified as federal law and court
bankruptcy courts federal bankruptcy
court and so I just sent them bankruptcy
papers and told them you know just
remove the account don't report on the
account anymore you're not allowed to
report on it because he can't no longer
exists meaning they can't keep reporting
it as bad debt after a bankruptcy on
your credit bureau report bankruptcy is
the line in the sand that's drawn the
chapter 7 clears it now the chapter 7
will stay on your credit report for 10
years but there the everything that
caused it stops on that date and that's
the way you look at it so good question
thank you for calling in I'm sorry you
guys are facing that but it sounds like
you're coming out the other side